call of duty infinite Warfare's
multiplayer may not seem that dramatic a
shift from last year's black ops 3 but
there are some important lessons and
tips for those of you jumping in to
consider here are a couple of them it's
essential to master wall running sliding
and thrust jumping as it greatly
improves your ability to traverse the
environment which in turn makes you a
harder target to hit
for instance wall running and thrust
jumping can throw off enemy fire while
sliding can be used to quickly zip into
cover take the time to understand how
each of these actions affect your
mobility as performing them recklessly
is likely to get you killed
always keep an eye on your radar this
may seem like an obvious one but
beginners often forget it even exists
the radar is an incredibly useful tool
that reveals both allies and enemy
locations
infinite Warfare's biggest change is the
new class system combat rigs which are
special classes you can choose they each
offer their own distinct weapon and
abilities with six different rigs to
choose from it's easy to stick to one
you're comfortable with however each
combat rig has their own unique weapons
and abilities that make them fully
capable of racking up a large string of
kills even if you think a combat rig may
not be suitable to your play style it's
best to experiment with each one a
greater understanding of each one makes
you a better player overall as it not
only enhances your knowledge of what
each one can do but how you can counter
the others as you play the various
multiplayer modes you'll start to earn a
currency called keys these can be used
to purchase supply drops which are loop
boxes that net you a set of three random
items which include prototype weapons
combat rig items and personalization
colors supply drops can be purchased in
both multiplayer and zombies but it's
worth noting that the latter devotes one
of the three items you earn to a pack of
zombie mode cards if you don't play
zombies make sure you spend your keys
exclusively in multiplayer as doing
otherwise will only be a waste in the
long run new to infinite warfare is the
addition of mission teams which are
special groups you can join that give
you objectives to complete during a
match accomplishing these objectives
earns you perks combat rig paint jobs
and prototype weapons that are each
unique to your mission team make sure to
complete your team's current objective
unit whenever possible the wards you
unlock are worth your time
unlike past Call of Duty games infinite
warfare lets you lob your grenade with
your left arm allowing you to continue
firing your weapon during the throwing
animation be sure to take advantage of
this as it can be a handy way to cover
yourself while throwing a cooked burn
aid towards a group of baddies prototype
weapons are some of these strongest
weapons in the game
so it's best to get your hands on as
many as possible
similar to loot games like destiny they
come in tiers common rare legendary and
epic you can acquire these weapons by
crafting them with Salvage opening up
supply drops or leveling up your faction
when playing defender pay attention to
the timer depending on the situation and
your placement on the map the timer can
determine the best course of action for
example if the timer is nearly up and
the enemy with the ball is far away try
seeking out the balls next spawn point
instead of pursuing it helps to be
methodical about the flow of the match
as opposed to mindlessly following the
ball wherever it goes don't hesitate to
shamelessly hide when you've got the
ball in defender there's no need to pull
over-the-top maneuvers your sometimes
better just finding a place to hide and
sticking there as the timer goes down if
you can't find a spot stay with your
teammates and keep moving away from the
enemy team and there are some tips to
get you guys started with infinite
Warfare's multiplayer are you enjoying
the game please let us know in the
comments below and have a great day